bonjour celle des taverniers voit tous
les martiniquais régulièrement les
franciscains qui nous écoutent
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes le
leader
le chef de file l'initiative
franciscaine l'opposition municipale à
maurice antiste françois merci d'être
dans l'ensemble a dit il ya quelques
jours dans face à la première édition
dominicale de notre rédaction ce même
maurice antiste laissé très clairement
tant qu'il pourrait se représenter à la
sénatoriale et que son mouvement
populaire francisque allait peser au
sein de l'alliance ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle autrement dit le
mouvement populaire peut envisager un
candidat dans la circonscription du
centre atlantique comment vous vous
observez tout cela dit nous sommes
attentifs à l'évolution effectivement
delà de l'échiquier politico françois
surtout et nous sommes également
attentifs à tout ce qui se passe dans la
circonscription du centre atlantique le
rappelez vous lors de l'élection la ctm
nous étions déjà présents et je vous
l'annoncé aujourd'hui de manière très
fort très forte
nous serons très engagé initiative
franciscaine au groupe pro 6 quai sera
très engagé dans les prochaines
législatives alors je ne sais pas ce que
feront les autres et en tout cas nous
serons fortement engagé dans la bataille
lorsque maurice antiste s'occupe
davantage de la chose parlementaire ça
lui prend de l'énergie pour la
municipale 2020 vous compter là dessus
mais ça lui prend de l'énergie ça lui
prend du temps puisque bombay il est
pratiquement absent de la commune donc
vous voyez bien que ça ne s'est lancée
par compatible 500 oui oui il est absent
et absent très souvent il sait pas gérer
son job de sénateur et celui de il dit
qu'il a une équipe et donc qu'il y à un
premier à déjouer qui fait le job
derrière mais savait que un maire doit
être prise en maximum de temps pour
gérer ses affaires surtout que les
affaires ne vont pas très bien la
commune du françois bon donc
donc cela soit véritable capitale du sud
atlantique on parle de francs soit dans
le sport on parle du françois dans la
culture ont pas lu france rof sur le
plan touristique n'être pas content ce
qui se passe dans votre premier vous
voyez vous avez effectivement dit tout
ce qui se passe au françois tout ce qui
se passe de positif et réalisé par des
privés et ou encore par des associations
au niveau sportif on alors que le
francis qu'elle agisse calyptus le
transit spa offrant six quais et j'en
passe et sans compter les yoles les
yoles qui nous donne beaucoup de fierté
et souvent je dis que maurice antiste et
ses collègues du mpf sont des rentiers
du sport ils sont des rentiers du sport
il ne freine un peu le fossile noah
social 60 ans la municipalité a quand
même mis quelques quelques quelques
quelques billes quand même dans le jeu
non justement en termes de subventions
par exemple il n'ya pas grand chose
quand on compare les subventions qui
sont versés à urcel qui sont versés
auprès de francis quai aux différents
clubs de la commune du françois rossé en
compte d'une grande disparité
nous avons du talent au françois et
c'est le talent francisque et qui se met
en oeuvre
mais derrière nos seulement ya pas des
moyens financiers pour le faire mais
deuxièmement les infrastructures ne sont
même pas aux normes
regardez le stade du françois vous
regardez la piste d'athlétisme du
françois qui est morte aujourd'hui
regardez un peu de tout ce qu'il ya
autour
allez vous vous rendez compte le hall
des sports par exemple qui délabré on se
rend compte que les sportifs risque et
n'ont pas les moyens dévolus à l'édition
pour s'exprimer dans de bonnes
conditions nous le dit en conseil
municipal a mais on le dit on le réclame
ou demande quels sont les budgets qui
sont mis pour le sport par exemple décès
0 c zéro cette année si vous regardez le
budget municipal
il y a que le poulet vers les vestiaires
du stade mais c'est tout alors que
l'éclairage est mort depuis un moment
vous vous imaginez une équipe comme
confié qu'il joue donc un duo qui ne
jouent pas en nocturne par rapport
effectivement un éclairage défaillant a
donc surgi au moment où le cléac'h
plutôt très différents jeux ça coûte si
cher et tendre communes l'ont fait moi
je travaille dans une collectivité et je
suis en mesure effectivement de faits de
faire des comparaisons concrètes
il y à des collectivités qui ont fait
défaut parce que objectivement et la
chose sportive elle est une chose qui le
pli est pris au cul et marié vous
proposez horizon 2020 aux franciscains
parce qu'on va le dire ça mais tavernier
initiative française qu'elle est déjà en
ordre de marche vous allez faire à votre
rentrée politique dans quelques jours
l'objectif c'est vraiment municipal 2020
oui l'objectif principal c'est les
municipales 2000 vais je voulais dire
les législatives nous sommes nous sommes
ne sont ni rédemption ne seront
fortement engagée mais pour les
municipales 2020
alors qu'est ce qu'on dit nous dit que
nous avons une commune charmante vous
avez dit à l'instant une charmante avec
37 km de littoral avec 8 il est vraiment
élégant la haute taille tout cela m'a
derrière pour mettre tout ça en oeuvre
dédiée il n'y a pas aujourd'hui la bonne
équipe je ne dis pas que mon ressenti
c'est contre une équipe n'ont rien fait
je ne dirai jamais ça parce que je suis
en collectivité depuis 32 ans
ils ont fait ce qu'ils pouvaient faire
et aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître qu'il
ya une usure depuis dépassé selon amélie
dépassé il ya 20 ans u20 tant qu'ils
sont là l'équipe est usé l'équipe n'a
pas de la nasa ronald équipe n'a pas de
ressort et par sa relève morrison il
relève mais nous aussi on se tiendrait
bientôt lavé sur cette relève qui est
préparé mais nous disons que nous avons
notre relève franciscaine ces
initiatives franciscaine c'est là que la
relève doit se faire et c'est pourquoi
nous proposons aux amis francisque est
bien d'être avec nous pour en 2001 les
français à refuser les marie marie
thérèse léotin c'est du passé au
françois
marie-hélène marie-hélène entériné au t1
c'est du passé qui ont fait du bon
travail mais aujourd'hui seulement deux
romandes ce ne sont pas des gens qui se
mobilisent aux commandes à la série mais
qui ne se mobilise pas sur le fond soit
je veux dire il y à une ou à défaut si
ce kane qui est là ces initiatives
franciscaine avec samuel tavernier et
nous comptons bien effectivement en 2020
arrivée aux affaires de manière à donner
un nouveau souffle à la commune du
françois
les législatives puisqu'on a dit vous
êtes en train de préparer votre votre
équipe initiative franciscaine
comment vous allez faire dans ce dossier
des législatives sachant que vous êtes
dans cette circonscription du centre
atlantique avec quand même une
particularité elle ferait de marie
jeanne qui a déjà fait savoir qu'il ne
se représenterait pas mais quand même il
va peser dans cette élection il sera
derrière celui que le mime va désigner
officiellement comment comptez vous vous
y prendre d'autant plus que vous n'êtes
plus avec notre plat divorce consommé à
160 oui c'est clair avec nous peu plat
on est plus on était leur pour la
septième excusez moi ça s'est bien passé
je ne regrette pas et je conserve
effectivement une amitié avec avec nadau
avec marcellin nadeau
mais n'empêche qu'il ya des aspects qui
ne nous convenait pas illégal cet aspect
sur le plan électoral et il remarquer
bien les choses on commence
effectivement à se gâter on va dire
entre initiative c'est ce que nous
peuple alors du deuxième taux à la ctm
nous avons pris notre responsabilité
alors que nous peuple indien ne voulait
pas se prononcer le deuxième taux nous
avons qu'une autre responsable et
guernesey marie jeunes et nous avons
demandé à au peuple martiniquais de
voter pour alfred marie-jeanne et de
barrer la route à l'aide chimie est bon
et vous attendent un retour sur
investissement avec tous ont leur cirque
arius est battable on l'a fait parce que
effectivement c'est notre cas naturel et
je vous le dis sincèrement lorsque nous
sommes allés aux élections à la ctm je
pensais moi samuel tavernier je pensais
que et bien qu'au deuxième tout
naturellement le rapprochement se ferait
avec alfred marie jeanne
voilà je le pensais maintenant il s'est
pas fait eh bien j'ai pris la
responsabilité avec mon gros de dire
'voilà votons alfred marie jeanne
et je rappelle que playlist hâtive de
2012 déjà en 2012 alfred marie jeanne a
été aidé par initiatives océanes sous
l'offre en soit difficile mais il le
reconnaît nous avons participé à sa
campagne activement et physiquement
doc autrement dit il n'y a pas de
problème pour nous de rapprochement avec
ce groupe là il est naturel comment
voyez-vous ce jeu politique de politique
politicienne dans cette circonscription
du centre atlantique
c'est que ça fait quand même au c'est
très compliqué votre regard
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
qu'effectivement il n'ya pas d'émergence
une émergence une forte personnalité qui
aujourd'hui peut dire qu'on va briguer
effectivement ce mandat de manière très
très facile
donc tout est ouverte la cause elle est
très ouverte et c'est pourquoi parce
qu'elle est ouverte on se dit que nous
eh bien nous y serons également nous
autres les pattes vous avez des jeunes
certaine karine rousseau
oui mais bon ça ne me gêne pas dire
ensemble est pour bat payant chance avec
karine rousseau n est pas l est du grand
ensemble et elle a été de rassembler
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas s'il sera
toujours d'hugo semblé lors des
législatives
ça se fait grâce à ce problème mais en
tout cas le guen mousseau nous avons des
rapports cordiaux et nul doute que
bombay il s'il ya des décisions à
prendre sur la circonscription on va se
rassembler ils se réunirent peut-être
pouvoir comme on vous serez tentés par
exemple prendre votre téléphone et
d'appeler le frère de marie jeanne pour
lui dire béchat besson j'ai commenté
soutien nous pour ce deuxième tour la 7e
le comptage et la bague à l'arrêt de la
cailloux oui je peux être le candidat
neutre qui ferait l'unanimité
nos chabé à une très bonne mémoire et il
sait tout ce qui vit à savoir maintenant
c'est à lui de points de ces décisions
est ce qu'il voudra de l'allier et vaka
jeunes de 7 à 15 ans exactement je pense
que le mime à une tradition ils vont
d'abord présenté quelques de la maison
de chez eux
d'accord du mime maintenant au deuxième
tour si jamais il ya le prix avec le
tavernier d'entre nous reste que ça vole
au mondial et des de perdre de l'énergie
du temps et de l'argent
elle est un premier tour d'une
municipale d'une législative
nous on savait que c'est pas une perte
de temps et c'est pas une perte d'argent
la plus fréquentée vont cesser de
l'investissement qu'on est d'acheter de
l'électricité en 2020 écouter mais il
faut pas être absents sur la scène
politique à ces rendez vous majeur et
nous nous serons présents je ne dis pas
encore quelle sera la forme de notre
engagement
en définitive on sera prison le groupe a
défini ensemble quelles stratégies
menées pour pour ces législatives
oui que pour ces législatives que pour
ça pour l'instant puisque bon nous ne
sommes pas intéressés par les par la
sénatoriale et sénatoriales nous serons
quand même
les acteurs puisque nous serons nous
allons dans un bulletin de vote nous
sommes des élus soit 6 quai est tout
sauf anti soit fortis non mais nous ne
voterons pas autiste ça il le sait déjà
mais pas tous sauf antiste dans l'enfer
quand même des choix judicieux nous
regarderons effectivement les
propositions qui seront faites et puis
bien ensemble avec le groupe initiatives
franciscaine on va choisir effectivement
les meilleures candidates à l'or va
rester encore 30 secondes sur maurice
antiste en tant que sénateur son action
comment vous la jugez je n'ai pas
beaucoup de vues sur son action au
départ j'ai beaucoup suivi
je ne crois pas que ce soit un bilan
très positif on a pas entendus sur les
grandes questions donc qui concerne le
pays on a entendu sur des prises de
positions sur des petits sujets par
exemple on a entendu sous les chèques
aux place dernièrement alors que de la
martinique effectivement des problèmes
particuliers économique de développement
bien j'ai trouvé que c'était hors sujet
justement de la seconde l'est de gaza
bon bref mais en tout cas je ne pense
pas que les martiniquais garde un grand
souvenir de mousses anti sa toxine merci
d'avoir été avec nous sa vieille taverne
eux rappelle que vous êtes le chef de
file d'initiative franciscains qui fera
sa rentrée
bientôt courant novembre aux noix de
novarama merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nous ça me tavernier de d'initiative
franciscaine bonne journée merci